[Musique]
je suis sûr que vous avez tous déjà
pensé à changer le monde
je suis sûr que vous êtes tous déjà dit
mais qu'est ce que je peux bien faire à
mon niveau je suis donc là pour essayer
de vous donner une réponse comment
changer des traditions bien établies
mon idée loge dans deux mots le mot
transmission et le mot tradition
quel rapport me direz-vous si je vous
parle de tradition là vous pensez plutôt
à quelque chose de culturel
d'authentiqués plutôt quelque chose de
stable de fix qui passe d'un individu à
un autre qui perdure
parfois on a envie de d'anéantir une
tradition parfois on a envie de la
conserver mon père disait la tradition
c'est l'anti modernité si je vous parle
maintenant de transmission là on est
plutôt dans quelque chose qui bouge on
est dans du mouvement on passe on passe
quelque chose d'une personne à une autre
d'un lieu à un autre on transmet alors
si je vous parle d'une transmission
d'une tradition là on pas en parle de
quelque chose qui bouge qui est en
mouvement d'une chose fixe y'a pas comme
une contradiction
et si en fait la tradition innovait si
la tradition changé je vous dis ça parce
que c'est quelque chose que
j'expérimente dans mon métier parce que
mon métier c'est d'être ethnologue et en
tant qu ethnologue on apprend et on vit
sur son terrain que les choses les
traditions en fait tu bouges être
ethnologue c'est quoi c'est étudié une
culture étudier une population une
société où c'est ça on pose beaucoup de
questions
ça peut être un peu gênant pour nos
interlocuteurs
donc si je parle de deux auteurs
s'appelle hobsbawm et rangers qui ont
aussi travaillé sur la tradition ils
vont nous dire qu'en fait une tradition
elle passe d'une génération aa une
génération b et que la génération b se
souvient de la tradition de la
génération a comme elle peut c'est à
dire qu'elle peut pas se souvenir de
tous les éléments de la tradition elle
est obligé de sélectionner certaines
parties certains éléments de la
tradition ça veut dire qu'il ya des
zones d'ombré et les interstices dans
lesquels en fait la tradition peut
innover et changer finalement la
tradition besson un peu différente de la
tradition à mais ça restera inconscient
par exemple si je veux refaire le gâteau
traditionnel de ma grand-mère et que je
me suis en à peu près tout ce qu'elle
faisait et qu'elle mettait beaucoup de
beurre eh bien peut-être que je me
souviens plus exactement de combien de
beurre elle mettait mais je vais mettre
beaucoup de beurre comme je pense que
c'est donc je mets une plaquette de
beurre je me dis que c'est beaucoup
je fais mon gâteau il est très bon c'est
toujours le gâteau traditionnel de ma
grand mère
sauf que j'ai oublié et tout le monde a
oublié qu'en fait elles ont été deux
plaquettes et le gâteau est toujours la
tradition pourquoi parce que le
changement reste subtil on est dans du
changement subtil
donc il est accepté et la tradition est
toujours valide
pour vous donner un exemple plus réel et
concret sur mon travail d'ethnologue je
travaille avec des populations
tibétaines qui vivent dans l'himalaya et
j'ai eu la chance de vivre dans un
village pendant cinq mois et de rester
avec une famille de médecins tibétains
donc dans cette famille avait le père et
le fils qui étaient tous les deux
médecins tous les deux pratiquent la
médecine tibétaine
une tradition mais il y à de légers
changements entre les deux pratiquent
tous les deux pratiques
la prise du pouls au niveau du poignet
mais aussi le mixage des herbes
médicinales des plantes mais finalement
il ya des choses qui varient pour vous
donner un exemple un jour je rejoins cet
ancien médecin avec qui je vivais qui
avait 75 ans je le rejoins sur sa
terrasse où il avait l'habitude de
passer beaucoup de temps et les toits
son plat donc lui il était assis là sur
sa terrasse à regarder le paysage et je
m'assois à côté de lui je m'assois à
côté de lui et on reste en silence à
regarder les montagnes à regarder la vie
du village
la route récente qui vient d'être fait
et puis on reste là silencieux et puis
soudainement spontanément il me dit ta
minh do 10 pts en mode homme à la mine
de mimine doula ma mine du chili à lier
pour vous le faire en français il me dit
il n'ya plus de chevaux il n'y a plus
que des voitures et des motos
il n'y a plus de personnes dans les
maisons il n'y a plus de médecin ils
sont à l'étranger
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que les choses changent
ça veut dire que la tradition
le monde change sous les yeux sous la
passivité en fait des yeux de l'ancien
et ce vieux médecin il se rend compte
que lui il a tout il est toujours resté
dans son village mais son fils
les médecins plus jeunes partent à
l'étranger par transmettre leurs
connaissances à l'étranger et apprendre
de nouvelles choses par exemple de
massage que lui l'ancien ne pratiquait
pas et son fils a aussi un impératif
qu'ils n'avaient pas qui est l'impératif
financiers on est dans un monde
il ya besoin d'argent et il faut
intégrer ça dans la pratique de la
médecine tibétaine puisqu'à la base
c'est une médecine dans laquelle il faut
être dans la compassion dans l'humilité
et ne pas demander d'argent en retour
aujourd'hui le fils aussi entre humilité
compassion et essayer d'avoir aussi de
l'argent parce qu'il faut bien vivre
donc la tradition change et cette
tradition change mais de manière très
subtile sa secteur dans du temps c'est
pour ça qu'elle est toujours valide en
fait la médecine tibétaine
on dit toujours que c'est de la médecine
tibétaine si le changement a été radical
imposer ça n'aurait pas fonctionné
si on impose du jour au lendemain de
changer la tradition les gens vont dire
ah mais ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on a
toujours fait ça marche pas pourquoi je
vous dis tout ça je vous dis tout ça
parce que si on prend conscience qu'on
change soit même que la tradition en
tout cas change quoi qu'il advienne dans
l'autre c'est quelque chose
d'inconscient fête de génération en
génération elle change eh bien ça veut
dire que peut-être que c'est par là que
les changements qu'on souhaite voir dans
le monde vont passer c'est à dire le
fait de prendre conscience qu'une
tradition change quoi qu'il advienne
qu'elle change que ce qui a toujours été
comme ça change quoi qu'il advienne
eh ben on se rend compte qu'on peut
soi-même changé est de l'auteur de ce
changement
par exemple si vous travaillez dans une
entreprise il ya la tradition de la
pause café
et que faites vous en avez marre
peut-être de boire du café soluble parce
que c'est la tradition voix du café
soluble et vous avez envie de voir du
café filtre mais si vous dites du jour
au lendemain maintenant on a une machine
à café
peut-être que les gens montrent un mel
ans pas comme ça qu'on a toujours faire
on a toujours eu du café soluble donc
peut-être que vous pouvez penser à
ramener votre tasse thermos de café fils
de la maison et commencer à en parler
avec les gens dire que c'est meilleur
pour la santé
les gens vont commencer à réfléchir ou
peut-être qu'après vous pouvez amener
votre propre cafetière tout en gardant
le café soluble
après les gens vont commencer à faire du
café filtre pour eux-mêmes et petit à
petit la tradition va changer mais la
tradition sera toujours la même on ira
boire du café mais elle aura changé
subtilement ce que je veux vous dire
pour terminer c'est que on a tous une
force de changement
elle est pas violente elle est subtil et
on peut l'utiliser à bon escient donc
utiliser là parce que c'est par les
petits succès qu'on opère de grands
changements merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]